hi there people so a lot of you have
asked me how I read papers and honestly
I don't think there is any super special
method to it but you know I thought
because people have asked me to make a
video on it so I'll make a video on it
and I'll try to share my method of
reading papers and hopefully this is
going to be somewhat of a miniseries or
a series where I every now and then
discuss how I read one of the papers
that I make videos about and I'll try to
select them such that different things
are highlighted now I've selected this
one right here for really for no
particular reason other than I sort of
remembered it and going to try to go
with you through how I read this and how
I encountered this and kind of try to
honestly share what I thought at the
first time when I read it and I hope
this helps some of you if it does help
you and if you like content like this of
course feel free to share this out and
subscribe if you haven't seen my
original video on this paper it might be
worth to go watch it I'll link it and
with that let's dive in so again this
might be not really something new but
I'll just go through it okay so first
thing I do is of course read the title
so the title has three parts and to end
object detection with transformers so
what I notice that I do myself is I like
through reading a paper
it's like read the paper with an open
mind I don't do that
I almost immediately form an opinion and
a hypothesis of what's going on like so
I see transformers so I know what
transformers are if you don't I've made
a video if made lots of videos on
transformers attention is all you need
is the base paper for that so I know
what a transformer is okay and I know
that transformers are usually in NLP are
usually used in NLP door there are
things like you know other things with
transformers but
usually an NLP model then I read object
detection and I know object detection is
a computer vision tasks so immediately
this here is sort of a a difference and
I immediately try to assess what's the
new idea in this paper and in this case
it might be okay it might be applying
transformers to object detection but
then I also see end to end and the only
reason to put that in a title is because
that's the novelty because usually in
deep learning we're sort of used to
systems being and to end and even if
they aren't if most systems aren't
end-to-end a lot of people don't is like
end to end image classification on image
net like Thanks so I I was guessing that
the reason they put in end-to-end into
the title was because that's actually
something that's special about the model
so now I have like two competing
hypotheses of why this paper matters
first of all because it does it with
transformers and second because it does
it end to end and the of course the true
fear is that the combination of end to
end transformers all of that is what
makes this model and I already form like
a hypothesis of whether I like this or
not like I have to be have to be honest
I have very quick judgment of papers of
whether I like them or not and then I
sort of catch myself each time and I
still try to so they're for most papers
actually that I have sort of a negative
opinion at the beginning where i will-
there are papers where I think like
there is no way this is going to you
know work or something like this I'm
actually positively convinced throughout
the paper so for most for most papers
where I that I read I'm trying to find
the positive things in there but I do
form an opinion pretty quickly usually
alright so the second thing this part
right here I like I don't even see this
is like advertisements on on like
Twitter I like you you just I have
always had issues with author names like
people would come to me and be like oh
have you seen the new vineos paper and
no clue and then when they say like oh
that's where they use this character
level model to do that and I'm like oh
that paper so I like do not care who the
authors are of a paper like I don't I
can't remember the papers by their
author names I've gotten better at it I
have to say but i-i've always had
trouble with this now that's not to say
that a name doesn't pop out to me like
if this would be like it like yoshua
bengio or some someone like really
famous then of course that would catch
my eye and but I also know that you know
yoshua bengio is paper
yoshua bengio slab is huge so just
because a big name is on the paper
doesn't mean that the paper is going to
be of any good or bad quality sometimes
the author's give you an indication of
what kind of research is there like if
you see a Najaf Clun or Ken Kenneth Oh
Stanley you know that there's there's
going to be the certain type of of you
know learning to explore and and and
kind of a bit more out-of-the-box
thinking in their papers which I really
like but it doesn't immediately give you
a clue maybe if you go by first authors
it's much more indicative if you have
already read some of their papers but
most often I just ignore authors and go
on the affiliation sometimes matters in
in that it's a bit of a vicious cycle if
there's a big name affiliation like
Facebook AI Google ai and so on these
papers also they get more exposure in
like the press and so on so whatever
Google a publish that paper all of these
all these pops eye magazines like verge
and this and life hacker and hacker news
and whatnot they like like write a blurb
about it so often they get much more
scrutinized for these papers they get
much more they get much more the public
attention but they also get much more
scrutiny which in turn means that there
is a bit more pressure on them to do
good experiments so that biases meet
like a little bit into the direction of
believing their experimental evidence
more now usually this is also backed up
by the fact that I am actually convinced
by their experiments usually so these
these big-name papers often I find
myself even without or
disregarding the affiliation to be
convinced more than of like regular
papers my most often issue with papers
is that I don't believe the experiments
and I make no difference like even if
it's Facebook I still my prior is the
experiments or crap and I don't believe
them and they have to convince me of the
opposite but some like I can't say that
it doesn't affect me that it's like a
big name affiliation okay so then the
second thing is I sometimes I see the
paper on archive and I skim the abstract
sometimes the abstract is informative
and sometimes not so here it's like blah
blah blah a new method that views object
detection as a direct set prediction
problem I'm like oh yeah okay so
streamlines the detection effectively
removing the need for many hand design
components like non maximum suppression
yada yada yada the main ingredients
called detection transformer asset based
global loss that forces unique
prediction via bipartite matching and
the transformer encode or decode or
architecture so they make it clear here
why it matters and that's that's what I
what I want to get at is sort of what's
the new thing in this paper most papers
are even though they're all very long
and have lots of math and so on
they often have like one or maybe two
new core things that they really tell
you sometimes zero but a lot of times
it's like one thing that they really do
and you you sort of have to but they're
trying to cloak it often because they
need to make their research as impactful
as possible right but you need to sort
of figure out what it is they're doing
they make it fairly easy for us in that
they say okay they remove the need for
many hand designed components like non
maximum suppression which tells me that
they're building something that's easier
than what came before them and that
already tells me it it's not necessarily
going to be better their argument is
more that it's going to be easier right
there there are sort of two kinds of
experimental results the ones where you
try to beat what came before you and the
ones where you're trying to say look our
thing works just as well as this other
thing while being more advantageous in
some other metric so I would place this
already in the sort of second category
and then they say what are the actual
ingredients it's a set based global loss
that forces unique predictions via
bipartite matching now I at this point I
know what these terms mean but at this
point actually don't have to know what
the terms mean what I need to recognize
is that I simply have to go later and
figure out what that is and a
transformer based encoder/decoder
architecture okay so there are two
things right here that I remember I need
to pay attention to later there is this
loss which seems to be special and there
is the transformer architecture which
seemed which they say okay that that's
the model basically consists of those
two things and then they have a short
description of what it does given a
fixed small set of learned object
queries that your reasons about the
relations of the objects and the global
image context to directly output the
final set of predicted in parallel that
almost tells me nothing of yeah okay the
model reasons maybe this in parallel is
something but the model is conceptually
simple and does not require specialized
library unlike many other modern
detectors this sort of repeats this
enforces my hypothesis that they're
going with the hey this is a much easier
way of doing things
approach detter demonstrates accuracy
and runtime performance on par with well
established that further confirms my
hypothesis that this is on
are right they runtime performance on
par with the current state of the art
and at the end they say moreover data
can easily be generalized to proceed to
produce Panoptix segmentation in a
unified manner we show that it
significantly outperforms competitive
baselines training code and praetor
models are available as part when I
first read it is like ok can easily be
generalized to produce this Panoptix
segmentation this is I didn't know yet
whether this is like a central claim of
their paper that it can do this
segmentation or whether this is like an
added benefit to their paper because you
can read it in both ways and I'm just
ready to find this out in the paper now
after I've read the abstract and sort of
already form the hypothesis of what's
going on so here I already in my mind I
already sort of have a model of how
would I do that
right how would I how would I do that
and then what would I do so right now
what I might be thinking is if I have a
transformer over images that directly
outputs the the predictions in parallel
I'm imagining like an image and the
image somehow needs to go into a
transformer so maybe there's like an
encoder like a CNN encoder that gives me
image features and then it's it's so
maybe you sample this down this image
this is just me hypothesizing what could
be going on right and then I might be
unrolling that right this image into a
vector of these lower pixels and then so
in my mind what I would do right here if
without knowing anything more would be
to do something like Bert's pan
predictions so I would have Bert right
here and I so for I would input this
sequence right here and then to detect
an object I would sort of think that
maybe the Bert you know Bert has an
output that is the same length as the
input right so it's it's very good at
sequence tagging and things like this so
maybe how it detects an object is going
to be that it sort of like tags the tags
the center location in the pixel of an
object right here or a tag somehow the
corners of the of the bounding box but
then I don't know how this is going to
be in parallel maybe Bert outputs like a
score for each location and then you do
some kind of matching right here so this
is my initial hypothesis of what's going
on and then I scroll through and
honestly the first thing I do is I go
and find the pictures and know no
different in all like since since you
first book you read that's what you do I
go and find the pictures because usually
if someone proposes anything new that
they're gonna try to make a picture of
it
luckily I don't do like super
theoretical what not your Bayesian
generalization bounds and I don't know
so most often papers I read have some
sort of picture and that's very helpful
to me I know I know but yeah so I find
this picture and here I see okay you
have image you have CNN okay gives you a
set of image features or so far so good
then transform or encoder decoder then
set of box predictions so all of them
come out here and I already read they're
in parallel and then bipartite matching
laws so here they I can see they color
these in different ways and these color
appear to match with these colors right
here right in the green here and these
they they also this is a very good
graphic but from this I can already read
that these here go to the no object a
lot of times the graphics aren't very
good so this this is where I'm not
saying in every paper you can learn by
looking at the graphics like sometimes
the graphics are terrible and you're
like what's going on here I like I don't
this this makes no sense
this happens a lot in this paper right
here this happens to be very very good
explanatory graphics so I'll take
advantage of that and I do the same
thing in the other papers right but then
later when it doesn't match what I read
in the text
I'll have to you know update my belief
and so on but here I see that these go
to no object and this goes to no object
so I don't know yet that this is the
test set at the point where I read this
I was sort of confused by this but I
recognized that each of these boxes
right here is going to be either
resulting in a bounding box or in the no
object prediction so from that I could
conclude that these things here are
maybe some sort of a fixed set right but
I still thought that you know these that
this would actually be the output of
these image features so that in this
case you'd have like six set of image
features and then you'd have like Bert
here even though that's not an encoder
decoder I still this was still my
running hypothesis that somehow you'd
map these image features to these boxes
right here so and I didn't know what to
what to make of this this thing right
here so then I went through some more
and look for more pictures and there are
not sometimes I also kind of glanced at
the formulas but okay when I Everest I
see this this is just I mean this is
kind of useless like okay cool you
minimize the loss thanks this okay
didn't really pay attention to that ah
new picture cool so this picture is much
more informative than the other picture
yeah I believe with the other picture
they were trying to show case this loss
how they do the matching and even though
I could read a lot from that picture I
did not get that part and that therefore
I felt when I saw this and I just
glanced at it I'm like wait what
what's different then up here it seems
like the same but okay let's look at
this so again we see okay you have set
of image features that comes out of the
CNN so that conforms with my belief but
then this here goes into a transformer
encoder and this comes out so
immediately I see oh this is not the
same
as these boxes here right that was my
hypothesis that these things here would
be the colored boxes so I I say okay
obviously that's not what happens this
thing here seems to be sort of the
encoded image information then that's
somehow fed into here and that then
there are these object query things and
they seem to correspond to this so I'm a
bit more confused right now what I can
see is that these then will result in
these in these boxes okay so being
confused by that I look for more
pictures so I go look for more pictures
and this here seems to be like of a
visualization a lot of these papers have
some sort of ablation experiments or so
and so on this I just find a really cool
picture for now I don't know yet what it
means this I don't know yet what it
means and I go down skip off this and
then back here in the appendix I find
this here which I immediately map to the
previous where this is the anchor and
this is a decoder and I've already read
the attention is all you need paper and
at that point it clicked and means like
this is not a Burt transformer this is
one of these transformers that has an
encoder and the decoder even though they
told me like 50 billion times already I
was too stupid until this point so now I
know okay okay I see what's going on so
the image goes through here and then
this goes as a side input like as an
attention from the decoder to the
encoder like I know in NLP right so in
NLP this here would be a source sequence
like maybe if you do translation and
this here would be a target sequence so
now whenever I see a transformer like
this and it outputs something this I I
look at it as okay this here is sort of
the input that goes as like a side input
over here and usually here you have the
target sequence but that's not the case
right here right you have
these object queries so this is how far
I get from the pictures now I go up so I
have a sort of I have questions now I
have questions and that's when I start
reading the paper only now do I start
reading the paper after I've looked
through all the images form the
hypothesis and sort of have questions on
how this works and we'll go a bit faster
from now on - just not bore you with all
the things so the introduction is often
very important even though it's called
introduction and maybe you know if you
read a book like if there's like
introduction or a prologue or something
like this it's often kinda pointless
introduction in these research papers is
one of the most important points because
all of these papers they try basically
all of them try to convince a reviewer
to accept them and in order to do that
they will set up their main points and
their main story immediately in the
introduction so what you'll usually have
is a problem statement which is here
like why what's what's wrong right now
and then you have like a story of how
their paper addresses the issue okay and
that's that's here we streamline the
training pipeline by viewing object
prediction yada yada yada
this is often formulates in words what
the paper is about and what contribution
the paper makes right this is like a
this is like a longer abstract the
abstract is often very very cryptic very
dense this here is often much more
informative of what the paper does so
for understanding the paper and a high
level the introduction is the best place
but given that I've already looked at
the images and so on I don't actually
draw many new much new information from
this thing then is related work and
honestly I I skip it like unless I'm the
actual reviewer of a paper like when I'm
the reviewer of a paper I read the
related work but often related work is
just
like you first of all you site a bunch
of your friends and then you cite the
mandatory papers and then you cite every
single person that you think could be a
reviewer because or you've actually been
rejected from a conference with a
reviewer claiming that your you haven't
compared or you haven't cited data or
that paper you can pretty much be sure
that that's the if if it's not a glaring
of may omission if it's like a niche
paper and you haven't cited it then
you're like okay I'm gonna cite it just
because the next conference you could be
Mary viewer again so I'm not I'm not
sure that these related work sections
they're necessary like if someone wants
to write their theses and they go and
read this paper and they want references
oftentimes this is a good place but a
lot of it is just blah blah blah blah
blah okay
I know disagree with me if you want oh
yeah - maybe - reading quality so I tend
to at this point I tend to not skim so
at first I skim but at this point I tend
to read every sentence and read it
closely and understand it and when I
realize like I'm tired or something I
don't just skim the paper I've tried to
skim papers and it doesn't doesn't work
try to read every sentence understand
every sentence and okay if you don't
understand it don't stop reading because
of that but try to not skim and be like
oh yeah yeah yeah okay I gotta go to go
to get away that is not helpful except
related work skip completely cool then a
lot of times in this paper now is the
the model and this is the section I'm
actually interested in right so I read
very very closely here and then I find
out what their their loss is all about
and again I stress read these things and
understand them right sometimes it's
hard but if you're if you're confused
that means you either if they've done a
bad job or they made a mistake or that
you haven't under
stood something if you can't understand
the sentence try to read on
maybe it's clarified later and then you
know go back but again do not do not
like just start a lot of times when I
read paper previously like I wouldn't
understand something quite well yet and
then I would be like oh yeah yeah yeah
and then I noticed that I start skipping
and skimming more and more because that
would you know pop up again and again
and I wouldn't understand it again and
again and then at the end I would just
be kind of glancing at the paper and I
don't want to do that right here so I
want to read every sentence and
understand it okay so here then I find
out about the loss and then I if I don't
know something here then I'll go and
look it up on maybe on Wikipedia or
something like this now I don't need to
understand every single part of it
right that's maybe I should correct
myself so for example this bounding box
loss here they talk about the second
part of the max across the Hungarian
Falls is this box loss that scores
bounding boxes unlike many detectors
that do box prediction with some
Englishmen
the other yada-yada they say the most
commonly used l1 loss will have
different scales for a small so here
they basically talk about how they mix
the losses they say overall our box loss
is that defined as this and this now I
haven't I don't know what these losses
are I just assume there are some
bounding box losses so when I it's not
true when I say understand everything
understand the things that are integral
to the story of the paper right how
exactly they compute bounding box losses
at this point I don't care I just assume
that there is some loss that I can back
propagate right I what is important is
that they do this Hungarian matching
thing right as soon as I get that I'm
like ah that was this you know this um
this thing no this thing up here this
thing this with the matching thing now I
get it now I know uh there are always
the same amount of boxes here
there are always the same amount of
labels here and all we need to do is
somehow match them and I immediately
think why is that relevant
oh because when something is already
matched to an object some other thing
cannot be matched to the same object and
that's how we you know prevent the fact
that all the things predict the same
thing right and so that immediately
becomes clear and as I said there is
usually like one or two ideas in a paper
I don't assume or I don't care what
their exact loss function is because
I've sort of gotten the idea up here of
what the loss is about alright so I hope
that's clear under very closely read the
things and understand the things that
are necessary for the story if you find
if you think something's not necessary
for the story and then later end up not
understanding that maybe come back and
you know read it again in any case I
would I would rather I would rather skip
something and assume it's not necessary
if I think so and then come back then
trying to understand every everything
but the things I do read I try to
understand thoroughly okay
then there's the architecture okay and
that again I read closely and get
backbone ok transformer encoder ok and
now I understand much more closely a
decoder ok and here I get now finally I
get what this is about because n objects
in parallel yada yada yada these input
embeddings are learned positional
encodings that we refer to as object
queries and similarly to the encode we
add them to the input at each attention
layer so now they name i've already seen
these object queries here and the only
word i actually need from this sentence
are learnt the fact that their
positional encodings I just kind of
ignore as soon as they say learnt I know
AHA these things here are learned they
have actually they're always the same
for each of the images they're just over
all learned okay so now I feel I
understand the entire model and yeah so
then they say auxiliary decoding losses
and this sometimes you have to pay
attention to like exhilarating because
those are the things that here they say
explicitly we found helpful to use
auxiliary losses sometimes they they
won't say why they did it they will just
say our loss consists of three things
and you know if you look at the three
things only one of the things is really
a part of their story so far and that
you should immediately conclude that
they've put in the other things because
they tried it and it didn't work right
so you can also kind of get an estimate
of the brittleness and so on of the
system in that you see how many
unnecessary things are there or how many
things are not straightforward how many
things aren't the easiest thing that you
would do when you would go about and do
what they did okay so then you this
concludes this model or method usually
the student section is called like
method or model or something like this
and you go to experiments now the main
question I have so far or I have maybe I
have some more questions about the model
itself that I haven't been able to pick
up from this section which is not the
case here but I simply keep those
questions in mind and see whether they
are resolved later right so I keep an
awareness of what I don't understand but
from here on my main issue is are they
demonstrating that their story works
right so they're here they're they're
proposing a loss and a model and in my
mind they now need to convince me that
that works and that's that's it's not as
easy as simply to show me some numbers
that they are good at some benchmark
they need to show me that they get those
numbers because of what they claim so
here they claim well okay they propose a
new they propose a new architecture so
what they need to convince me of is that
the architecture itself makes sense
right but in other papers when when you
propose like and when you say like oh we
for example in an L STM when you build
in an attention mechanism and you claim
oh we you know the attention mechanism
can look back at the source sequence in
one step then you need to convince me
that that actually happens right so you
need to not only need you need to
perform well you need to convince me
that you perform well because of what
you claim your model does right so and
that's often difficult and I
specifically look out in the experiments
for usually the question is like where
are they trying to me right
where are they trying to are or are they
trying to me are they trying to
cover up the fact that something doesn't
work now all the experiments are always
in the best light possible of course and
you have to keep that in mind but a lot
of times you can also already see from
the experiments that okay are they doing
something weird are they not showing me
some obvious experiment or and that's a
lot of time because is there an easier
explanation for why they get the results
that they get other than their
explanation right and it is it is their
job to convince you that their
explanation is the correct one for these
numbers and especially if there is an
easier one that they haven't excluded
and then I don't believe the experiments
if that's the case right if there is an
easier explanation for the effect I'm
I'm very skeptical but some papers have
an easier job here than other papers so
in this paper they basically show
results on a on a on a task and since
their paper is about hey our pipeline is
just easier than other pipelines what
they first of all need to do is they
need to like match the numbers of other
pipelines and here I see that okay in
these results often in the aftermath
maybe a table or something here you see
like this their model other models and
their model is the best model in a lot
of cases now if the best thing is of
course if is if their model throughout
is the best the worst thing is if it's
like scattered like this even if their
model is the best but in every single
benchmark a different configuration of
their model is the best that's that's
sort of a bad sign unless they can
explicitly explain why that is and it's
also not that good of a sign if these
things are spread out like this like
sometimes this baseline is good
sometimes their model is better and so
on so pay attention to that now in this
paper it doesn't matter so much that's
actually fine because what they're
trying to show is that their model is on
par and way easier and they've already
made the case in what way it is easier
it's easier in terms of architecture if
there were to say it's much faster then
after that I would expect you know an
experiment in speed while these numbers
are matched so but since they say it's
easier I've already seen the
architecture I'm convinced of that now
that they show okay our numbers match
actually I'm surprised they even
outperform a lot of times then I'm quite
happy with these experiments so also
look for differences between numbers and
the spread of numbers now it's not easy
to say what if like point 1 is a bigger
a small difference that depends on the
task but if you know pay attention to
these things pay attention to the fact
that these results are noisy and
oftentimes there is a lot more hyper
parameter tuning going into the model of
the paper then into the baseline model
so why do you want to make your look
your stuff look as good as possible and
here is a little bit where the
institutional credibility of someone
like Facebook comes in in that I tend to
believe their results a bit more than
other results
megha but a bit more yeah also look at
patterns that they don't point out in
the text so if there is like a pattern
if you see like an interaction between
the number of parameters and the score
or something like this just try to be on
the lookout of that and see if you can
spot something that you think or think
about whether that makes sense or not in
what your hypothesis would be so here we
go on and okay then they go into
ablations and a lot of a lot of these
papers do appellations and i generally
appreciate that so here they visualize
that the attention mechanism in their
model actually refers to different
instances right encoder self attention
for a set of reference points the
encoder is able to separate individual
instances and you can see that pretty
clearly right here where and even here
with the overlapping cows and this is
the sort of experiment that I would
expect that actually convinces me that
their architecture does what it says
that it does right and something like
this where you see like totally
overlapping things with the attention of
the individual things visualized so
telling me like especially this one
right here the the foot of the back
elephant actually being focused by the
attention of the bounding box of the
back elephant that's the sort of
experiment that convinces me that their
claims like that their numbers really
come from what they claim it comes from
okay so at the end of the experimental
section you should always ask yourself
have they really convinced me that their
story is true right that the improvement
or winnig whenever they get an
improvement or whatever they get whether
is is due to the story that they want to
sell me or could there be like an easier
explanation or does something not fit is
like other are the experiments different
than from what you would
SPECT here okay so these are these are
my main questions are they are they
convincing me of their story it's not do
they have state of the art numbers I
don't care I don't care even though like
sometimes so there is a bit of a catch I
I don't care about state of the art
numbers now let's say you have a table
like this and you have a computer vision
model and one of the models is like on
the C for 10 data set now if your
baseline model has like a ninety one
ninety two percent accuracy on C for ten
when I know the state of the art is 96 I
don't care right I know like I've done C
for ten I know with like I don't know
five six layer CNN you can reach these
91 92 93 % accuracy and to get to the 96
97 you would actually be like in the
region of a wide ResNet and whatnot so I
you know I know that even though you're
a few points behind state of the art I
know you know this this is valid still
so I don't care but if you were to be
like at 80 percent accuracy on C for 10
then I then I get a bit like I like it's
pretty easy to get to 90 percent plus
with like a standard CNN so there I
immediately start to wonder why is there
an explanation now this could be like a
theoretical paper that says oh we
investigate MLPs and that's why we only
get that number so that's that would be
fine but if something is out of the
ordinary like this then I pay attention
but never because something isn't like
the latest and greatest state of the
earth that's just dumb ok and also if
only evaluate what the paper claims it
does right if the paper says we want to
show that we are on par with current
models then don't be mad if the paper
doesn't outperform these models they
didn't claim that right so yeah so after
these ablations I'm actually pretty
happy right here with the results and
this right here when I saw this I didn't
I didn't expect that but I read the
experiment description that these are
these different learned object queries
and what they do and that gave me an
increased understanding of how these
object queries actually work right so at
that point I still had like a vague I
knew that these are learned but reading
this and sort of looking at it studying
it a bit I was like oh okay then I
understood even better what they are so
again when I say understand everything
in the method section you can still have
questions and but you just have to keep
it in mind for later and then here I go
on and there's this de TR for Panoptix
segmentation and they here they propose
like a new model so I first look at it
and I'm like okay they proposed a new
model they can do stuff like this now
this is not object detection and again
I'm not sure is this like a is this like
a an add-on to the method or is was was
this up here just an intermediate step
to this and honestly after reading that
I still wasn't sure it seems like
something in between of course the paper
is also a bit longer than other papers
it just it seems it's too long for just
being a side note but it's too short for
being its own thing so that was just a
bit weird and I treated it as just like
a oh we can also do this with our model
but I didn't pay like too much attention
to that okay so at the end I you know
look at conclusions now the conclusions
of a paper are much much often they are
not nearly as informative as the
introduction the conclusions they all
often tend to be very generic and kind
of hedging a bit against criticisms
saying what would be up for future work
which is again hedging against criticism
because you could simply say well we
didn't do this that's future work yes so
again I read it but I don't really pay
attention to it and then I gloss over
the abstract I just would kind of scroll
through the abstract if there's
something that catches my eye I would
look at it and if not then not and then
I basically go to the start and whenever
I didn't understand something I go back
I look at it again and I try to think
are all my questions answered and have
they sufficiently convinced me that
their story is the thing that really has
the effect right here and then if I now
were to make a video of this I've often
found it useful to just put the paper
away for a while and it's I usually get
the best result when I read the paper
the day before and then make a video the
day after or if not I'll just you know
put it away do something else do some
email responding programming going
outside eating lunch just some kind of a
break between first read or between your
first couple of reads and just I don't
even think about the paper I just it's
kind of it's in the subconscious it kind
of bruised right and I happen to think
about the paper every now and then but I
don't make a conscious effort to be like
oh how am I gonna explain this and so on
but I just found the the worst videos
are the ones where I immediately make
the video after reading a paper and I've
just discovered that if I kind of take a
break and then I look at it again right
I look I don't read it fully again but I
if I have if I have the feeling I've
understood it I don't read it fully
again but I just kind of look at it and
go again through this story and I think
that's even if you you know wanna if you
want to talk about a paper in a reading
group or tell you know explain it to
your friends or whatnot this is often
very useful just put it away for a while
let it Mellow and I find that helps a
lot
okay that was my process of reading this
particular paper now we again this this
is a high quality paper so it's I find
it's a pretty easy read in that I simply
need to understand what they did and I'm
pretty happy with their experiments I
maybe next time I can find an experiment
or a paper where I'm initially more
skeptical and not as happy with what I
find but yeah let me know if you enjoy
this or if you would like to see any
other explanation I don't exactly know
if this is what you expect it from a
video like this so let me know maybe I
have misunderstood you completely or
it's way too long way too detailed or
way too undetailed yeah leave me a
comment and I'll see you next time bye
bye